hello and welcome everyone
my name is Hawken robbery and let's talk
about light and adaptive indexing for
mutable databases and I will start with
a mutable part and then work backwards
towards the indexing I work for a
company called juxt which is software
engineering firm based in the UK
but first let's go back to 1980 where at
this Workshop in Monterey South of San
Francisco George Copeland did present a
paper called what if Masters were free
this is a nice short paper which
investigates this assumption would mean
for database assumption systems I want
to focus on two main points first point
is deletion considered harmful this is
what I would call the functional
programming or engineering argument for
mutability that is improvements
functionality Simplicity Etc can
received by system by eliminating the
deletion mechanism this is a compelling
argument but it's main about internal
benefit for us as engineers and it's not
enough on its own
the second point is the importance of
access to past States in your memory no
deletion mechanism exists people do not
delete deletion was invented to reuse
expensive computer storage you could
call this the memory or history argument
for mutability and it's much more
important one as the external
user-facing benefit
because our trade is starting to be
Initiative for granted access to history
for this ability to reuse storage he
goes on giving various examples to this
why this is important like Trend
analysis auditing and historical
information Etc nothing with this has
actually changed in the past 40 years
since this paper was published which
shouldn't surprise us as a need for
these previous computers by thousands of
years
Copeland tries to try to sketch
something based on the kind of
technology has available in itself in
the early 80s which involves using write
once read many Optical disk
which is something which makes me think
about 1986 so I attended this radio and
television Fair Vision 86 with my mother
in Stockholm I was nine years old at the
time and a strong member of this being
an awesome event but I actually don't
remember anything from the event itself
beyond the fact it was the first time in
my life I saw a CD this was in an audio
CD cedar-ons were kind of coming a
little bit afterwards
Syria of course also from Optical discs
like the ones Copeland discusses seeds
are defined but it's called rainbow
books where the red books audio jealous
CD-ROM and orange is writable series Etc
now 700 megabytes of storage process an
immense amount of data back then right
there's several orders magnitude and the
kind of data I was kind of seeing every
day of course I was nine right like and
I do remember thinking a few years later
I may be able to kind of fill up a few
CDs in my entire life like that's kind
of really the kind of amount of storage
I would ever need this was later proven
wrong yeah now in 1986 I would have been
using the Commodore 64. I was using
tapes now a 60 Minute tape on the
Commodore 64 can store on each 30 minute
side around 100 kilobytes of data right
so this is the kind of storage I was
working with at the time right so I
found this book filing system for
databases or and database for the
Commodore 64 while looking for articles
in all my scenes which could kind of
inform a memorable because Vision 86
events which I kind of totally forgotten
like these books get quite good review
in the magazine like it has a really
good chapter about sorting apparently I
haven't read this book myself like I'm
sure it's easy to find a copy about of
it today but it gives they give it some
criticism for actually not bringing up
secondary indexes and only focus on
primary key lookups so we'll see I'm
gonna try to avoid this mistake in my
own talk like I haven't read this book I
said but it does not discuss the mutable
databases I'm prepared to guess yes so
later in the 80s I was only in Amiga a
store of still neither Mass nor free
like a considered amount of a limited
amount of money or spent on buying
floppy disks like and
20 megabytes not gigabyte right
hard drive cost more than the actual
computer you own right so this effect
simply beyond my means I could never
ever buy like a hard drive at this point
right like I would later get one like
early 90s sometime potentially
um now as Copeland point out I didn't
actually want to delete my diskettes
despite the costs and limitations of
these Flopper disks right there
like they actually work involved to
getting this data onto those disks in
the first place was just too big so
essentially people do not delete and I
didn't want to either despite this
yes so Davis was simply time of
physically moving media around right
they were carrying discs you're kind of
going off to the outside of town with
the Metro kind of buying discs from
someone you kind of got in contact with
from some ad in the newspaper you're
kind of sending disks to other side of
the country hoping they will come back
with something stuff on it you're going
to send cash usually with them as well
this kind of exactly swapping scene
essentially this was pirated stuff yeah
so even back then my inclination was
towards immutability like once you got
on hold or something you did not want to
get rid of it you bought more discs
essentially so on that note let's move
forward fast forward today 2022.
yes so towards immutability so we are
building an immutable database as our
company jocks this call X to be this
talk is not about xdb but I will have to
mention a few things but it's gonna
be easy for me to explain and inform
some of my thinking like
so most of the stuff I'm actually going
to talk about is based on academic
papers so it's like this threshold of
things you want to kind of dig into and
read and kind of learn from so there's
going to be a little bit of a meta
element of that as well like how do you
actually start doing this like we're a
small team we don't have any phds we
have like a lot of good Engineers but
we're not it's not our natural element
essentially yeah so reference to all of
these papers will be at the end and I
will post a link to the talk the slides
at the end of the talk so if you're
interested in any of this like there are
many ways you can enter this space right
and become interesting so yeah let's
have a look so when you think about
immutability in the actual industry and
today you may start thinking about
analytics or at least I think about
analytics because this space which
potentially moves a little bit faster
than transaction systems because you can
innovate a little bit more here right
like you're not as dependent on having
like low late transactions or like
full-on transactional acid correctness
like so you can build of the system and
people do this like a bewildering space
you have everything like you know
functional program inspired systems like
mapreduce you have data pipelines like
spark you have data lakes and table
formats actually manage these data Lakes
like this is just an immense smart stuff
you have the old data verbs and stuff
where you kind of append only fact
tables which you kind of introduce like
so there's an element with mutability
here right and because this data often
tends to grow there's also connection to
the concept of separating storage or
compute which is going to be a key theme
in this talk now an attempt to kind of
like say initial right we didn't
necessarily need to split this up but
it's like by historical extent the
industries kind of split in several
different directions so there is this
concept of hybrid analytical
transactional process in h-type which is
an idea of trying to bring this stuff
together again now there will always be
needs for like high performance
transaction systems very large data like
analytic systems but maybe for the
common case we could move back to like
an eight-step world for some use cases
right
so
separating storage of compute so this
line here right this is separation so
this is a common concept you will
already have recognized this in probably
already never heard of it or know it but
even if you think about your normal
applications you will usually have like
a stateless thing which is your service
and then you have a storage somewhere
else but your store to someone else's
service right for example it's a
database or in this case if you're
building a database the storage maybe
the orbit store like S3 S3 itself been
recursively also be separated in this
case like there will be some services
and there will be some Advanced thing I
actually don't know how it works but
we'll actually separate out the data
into various real world disks right yeah
so you have a granularity like
stair here essentially right like you
have small things on top like CPU cash
of course much smaller then you have ROM
you have the local disk which is only
used as a cache in these context like
you don't really want to store anything
but you're allowed to store and it's
especially easier when you're using
immutable data like so you can you
essentially know we're going to change
your files underneath you right because
you can just assume as a scenes you can
cache it the distributed cache is
totally optional but it's there for you
to kind of avoid touching the orbit
store in the first place so there are
several systems we're using this both
the kind of like analytics systems and
more modern kind of like each step
attempts or like different strategies
for trying to do this so
and we are also building one which kind
of uses this rough architecture now
here's an early paper from trying to
build in so that the idea of separating
storage compute is not new right but
trying to actually build a database in
this matter is yeah while not new it's
not like super recent you don't have
many of them actually maybe like at
least on some transactional side like in
production ready I'm saying they're
known right but like because it's almost
impossible to know exactly what exists
out there but anyway these papers is
from 2008 building a database S3 and
this is actually not about the
mutability they're trying to essentially
just replace the page buffer in a normal
database with S3 and then this instead
of writing local disk they write them
onto S3 and with this kind of works but
as you can see you're going to introduce
some kind of coordination between these
nodes in the paper use sqs to actually
coordinate between the notes to figure
out who is allowed to write which page
when so but anyway it's a cool
um like proof of concept idea like
and other related Concepts which is like
not directly separate Distortion field
but can relate to analytics on this
entire data that so many Innovations
coming from analytical side and now kind
of kind of moving in towards the
transactional side is the composition
storage model which is another Copeland
paper from 85 so at this point in time
coconut is working on like a small talk
obic database called gems Stone nothing
it later became like a Java database and
still exists potentially
so I actually have no idea how this
design relates to the orbit store stuff
but like in orbit database that's not
always storing the S3 sense yeah so
these column stores this is what we
today called column stores right like so
it's like it's an early paper he doesn't
use the term column stores but we tend
to refer to them as column stores today
there's also related concept called wild
column stores like Cassandra and stuff
but it's not really the same thing this
is all about like an efficient access to
a race it's quite in a way the basically
it's quite simple you're building things
with mechanical sympathy which works
well on kind of like sequential access
data which also it's hard or liquid
related to coming back to the kind of
mutual data which is kind of work with
append only data mostly when you write
so you prefer sequential reads
sequential rights of course you still
have random access at times so yes so
our system is an hdap column store so
this is how this is so much related so
here is Copeland's paper from 85. so on
the left hand side here you have what we
would traditionally call it called a
roaster like so this would be normal old
P postgres kind of database where the
rows are kind of like The Columns of the
rows are clustered together
so if you see on the left hand side you
see something called surrogate so this
is usually called like a tuple
identifier or row identifier or an
object and something which would
identifies the row itself in this world
this is still kind of like hanging
together
coconut first is the anarist or model
so on the right hand side this is
copen's variant of the columns in modern
column stores you don't always have the
third key but you use the surrogate
columns it's not just a value column
right you have two columns per column
and one of them is a surrogate some of
the circuits doesn't exist because the
index itself but this is what you use to
kind of correlate the different columns
together in some systems you wouldn't
necessarily have all of the values for
all columns like so you can potentially
row can have different columns from
another row so that's where you need is
kind of surrogate keys to kind of
correlate them back up together now
briefly our architecture is on the left
hand side we have SQL clients in the
middle is the compute this is our actual
system right so on top of your SQL
front-end secret planner we use arrow
for almost everything looks very kind of
a columnar database where the local
orbit cache is going to be more
interesting for this talk and then we
have a temporal but once you're in the
kind of mutual space It's relatively
easy it's kind of patch on by
temporality on top of that it's a
different features but like usability is
the foundation to do that we're not
going
is like an entire own topic on the right
hand side we have a right head log which
is like where you post data in and
that's going to synchronously be
processed on the nodes and then every
now and then right so this one this
this kind of like a gap or a buffer
problem right that you cannot write
every transaction into Adobe store
directly or you could and then try to
kind of merge them together but that
introduces a lot of latest and slowness
so you want to kind of buffer them up
but the durability in our system comes
from actually when it hits the log
itself then it's kind of like it's
durable eventually going to be reduced
into some kind of object when you get
enough of rows or like data so you can
write them down to the other store
this talk is about this piece right the
actual indexing which is what happens
when you need to efficiently navigate
the orbit store like so you're not going
to talk about columnar execution we're
not going to talk about power
temporality or SQL even though there's
interesting topics you're also not going
to talk about transactionality which is
so much related because it's like in
some overlap like when and how can you
read things like one very nice thing
about immutability now settling very
briefly into this topic is that you can
always take a watermark or kind of read
from like no one's going to change this
or come in so you don't really need like
any locks to do reads
um okay so what is the problem we're
trying to solve there right like what's
the real problem which motivates this
talk in the first place so I call it the
latest problem there may be like a
proper academic term for this right but
it's like
yeah share disk Strikes Back we have had
Decades of shared nothing architecture
we're like compute and storage is
usually coupled which like and then you
enter in this kind of sharding and
partitioning problems and this is kind
of like the mainstream way of doing
things I would say like but you're
starting seeing this more and more and
instead of kind of coming a little bit
from the analytical side first because
some have the same transactional
problems I'm not saying this will come
all over the place anytime soon but
there's
you can find a lot of papers workers
yeah so this enables cold transmission
right so of course it's not free mass
storage right like if you never get
fundamentally free but it's much much
cheaper than it could have been if you
didn't use something like an object
store
yeah the data still needs to be found
and navigated and this is like one of
the Crux of the problems right this is
kind of like part of the index and
probably needs from obviously have two
sides one is the kind of finding and
navigating the data the other is that
like because this introduced latency and
request costs you want to minimize
actually accessing the date in the first
place this is kind of like two sides
almost to the same coin that you need to
solve yes so what is the solution this
is kind of like my sketch solution are
we going to go into the details of this
through the talk right and a lot of this
section based on ideas from Academia but
I have to kind of adapt it a little bit
to our real engineering context right so
the solutions indexing and caching and
caching of indexes so indexing and
caching and caching or indexes so like
you need to kind of
this is the basic right you need to
create the right index and you need to
Cache everything and you want to avoid
ever falling off this Cliff occasionally
you will fall off the cliff but for
transactional processing that may not
even be acceptable considering which
circles as you're in right so what I
call light in index or Mutual index
stored in storage they are not
necessarily light in the sense that they
are small they are light in the sense
that they are simple to build and
they're very small compared to the data
the index you want to kind of like a
magnitude kind of like fan out from
these things right like the Adaptive
indexing are totally different right
they're running on the compute nodes and
they can use more Dynamic like the
specific techniques which are tuned to
specific workout time they're total
transient to disappear there is a
simplification here because there
actually is connection between these two
books you can use the Adaptive indexing
to guide what you actually want to build
the real kind of index for in the first
place so we need to turn to Academia for
inspiration or at least I need to turn
correctly for inspiration so now we're
going to look a little bit what we can
find there
yeah so this is kind of like a meta
slide but I think this kind of
interesting itself because like
it's not about reading one paper right
like you need to go through a lot of
papers and also quickly kind of ignore
most of the stuff you kind of find and
actually find the things that are
interesting to your problem because you
are not there necessary to kind of like
oh I'm gonna you know write this thesis
on this like I wanna you get some
techniques that other people have
thought about and be able to leverage
them in my engineering setting right so
what I would say is like you skimmed
abstract and you look for interesting
pictures it makes this may sound
simplistic right but actually when
you're gonna read a lot of papers you're
not going to read them I'm going to look
at a lot of the papers you want to find
like is this even interesting to me like
you wanna
definitely resist the temptation to
understand each paper I think it's quite
common you someone give you a paper you
can try to read it and try to understand
it if there's a time and place for this
but it's usually if you're trying to
find solutions to your problem right so
you want to find the pragmatic approach
via the references I would say you
usually find like there's some kind of
like groundbreaking paper which may not
even use the terminology like the
composition term um
paper is a good example of that right
but then lead to your good papers that
actually kind of like make a bit more
mainstream you can understand that but
between is a lot of incremental papers
just an incremental in increment which
you kind of like these are usually the
first you find and it's like what you
need to work yourself backwards
something actually works for you another
very important thing is you can use to
invalidate your ideas you can spend
forever trying to build things of course
you have 100 trust what papers say but
you can at least get a feeling like this
approach probably not worth spending
months building and then realize it
actually won't work right so in the end
like if you want to understand one paper
of course there are papers will love
this is good right it's a good way to
get started reading some academic papers
but it's not really the way to kind of
like it's going to be like very
established papers which probably was
going to be covered in textbooks and
stuff but it's a good way to start but
it's not going to give you this like
current like what's happening Academia
so archive.org is kind of like fire hose
you can just like so you I kind of
follow like yeah seven topics maybe
which are related to what I'm working on
and you get like those paper a day and
you need to skip most of them like so
and then once you find something there
which seems so much interesting you can
use something like semantic scholar or
to actually navigate a graph of papers
so this like we could talk a lot about
this but suddenly I don't have time but
there are also many other kind of sites
like this and lots of paywalls and
things in this place world but again
it's about reading papers not the single
Paper right like this is the problem
when you I have a specific engineering
problem I want to gain some
understanding for Academia
okay so a little subfield which is kind
of up and coming right now is this thing
called machine learning for database
system so I'm going to admit if you're
not going to talk about any advanced
machine learning it's going to kind of
underwhelming potentially if you come
here to hear something really really
heavy there is really like funky stuff
going on in this field but I'm kind of
main looking for more pragmatic stuff is
usually not that advanced when you start
looking into it so you have a few
different kind of research groups I want
to highlight we are kind of like the
self-driving databases group or like
thing from Carnage melon which Andy
Pablo and then you have like I would
also strongly recommend Elizabeth
related to the previous slide but
refining papers right and the Pablo has
these courses on CMU which are really
really good if you want to get into like
reading some papers understanding
database systems this has been like I
would not have been able to get halfway
without getting that kind of basis
because like when you start reading
random papers you can't really just do
that you need to have some minimal
foundation in order to actually want to
kind of connect it back to you have
adaptive indexing but structures Idris
at Harvard this is like one or like this
previous the machine learning thing so
I'm not even sure if you call this
machine but it's still part is kind of
entire adaptive learning doing funky
stuff based on your data right yeah
inside optimized systems from MIT they
Associated group that just learned in
this thing we're going to get that mixed
so one kind of rough idea is you want to
learn from the data like both they can
actually store data and also the kind of
metrics other things like there are
really interesting stuff around kind of
workload prediction and things like I'm
not going to talk about that because I
don't really know much about but I think
that's going to be Paramount to actually
make some of this stuff work for real I
said because you don't really want to
fall off the cliff hitting the storage
more than necessary even if that's even
acceptable so kind of if you want to
kind of a little bit like tongue and
Chic it's kind of like taking debate out
the loop you shouldn't if the computer
can figure out which indexes need to
exist and how they should look and what
data success you can use stuff like this
to actually go there
but of course this idea is not new like
so this is actually
and the powerless advisors advisor so he
mentions in blog posts I kind of took it
from there it's like in the selection
itself adaptive database Management
Systems so this is paid from seven to
six right so you like there's generally
really no new ideas right there is
rehashed in various ways
but this honestly is like a slightly
different approach but it's quite
interesting people so anyway let's go
into learned indexing itself
so I'm going to just use one example of
learned indexes because like the loads
of different papers obviously
to talk about this one which is called
Radix buy so this is not the first one
but it's a kind of simple which shows
someone's ideas so it's a single pass
index which means that it's actually
kind of like you
you don't need to retrain or like go
through this amount of times you can
just switch through data once it's by
Kip from 2020 and it estimates the
cumulative distribution function you
could say for Simplicity that this is
just a model which maps from keys to a
position
so you have a spline mapping from key to
position which you've got this model
builds and then on top of you add the
Radix layer so I'm going to show you how
this looks but first let's just show you
the general idea of learning so this
comes from the learn in case we learned
index structures
um by kraska 2018 at our
so this like on the left hand side of
the traditional B tree index which kind
of like you it's also kind of a model
you get like okay here's a position
which you have kind of code up through
your internal nodes and then you kind of
somewhere in this page it's my dating
constant generally of learned index is
that you're kind of like oh I have some
kind of more advanced or kind of in this
case a neural network I said we're not
going to talk about neural network it's
just some kind of model which then
country estimate within this error bound
this error bound is very important
because otherwise you don't get the
guarantees you need to actually able to
use these things in reality but so the
point right is that these are quite
light and small because you kind of
condense the data like the actual data
needs to be stored for indexes is quite
small compared to the data itself so
let's look at Radix blind so here first
x-axis your keys y-axis your indexes
here's an unsorted column so let's just
start by sorting it so this in a way
you're actually not by already you can
see this not single person that sense it
kind of usually assumes the sorted which
cannot really learn anything from the
random data right but
let's accept that we have sorted this
thing we're now going to build some
splines so these spline points is going
to be like a magnitude smaller in amount
and accelerator million data points in
the green CDF line there right you may
have thousand or ten thousand actual
spline points on which you can dig out
on this again a bit underwhelming this
is the machine learning step right how
to find is essentially at the spline
estimation curve fitting algorithm
um so on top of this they put a Radix
table so this in this case they're using
three bit Radix which means that you
have yeah three bits eight buckets and
what they just do is to look at each
blind point and every time the first
three bits change they put it like it's
almost like a skippies you could put
kind of like a shortcut so you can go
directly into this spline points you
never need to look at entire index
yep so you have an example of a query is
47183 in decimal it's a long number
binary I'm not going to read it but it
starts with 101 which is 5 in a decimal
so you mean this means that you can
directly Loop between five and six and
you will have a few spline points there
which you can actually then look so you
can skip most of the spine once it just
looks at these kind of you have three
essential points you can look at the
last point is not going to be ebooks
something starting with five will never
start with six so you can look with two
other points once you found a point
which is high lower than the thing
you're looking for like I mean if
well you find the highest point which is
lower than the thing you're looking for
and then you do a linear interpolation
there
so how do you build this spline
so here's another paper it's also it's a
bit early from 2008 smooth interpolating
histograms with arrogantries by Neumann
and Michelle
so you see there's not a lot of data
this thing actually fits the spline
so I'm going to try to walk this through
it's not going to be necessarily
like super clear but you can go to paper
you can look and read and understand it
but I've taken the diagram I'm breaking
down into the parts
so this all the white points or points
you're gonna assigned on these two lines
in the algorithm right like so B is the
new base point so what a base Point
means is that like when so this cone is
here this red thing this is like the
error bound which is the allowed error
bound it's going to shrink as you walk
your data you're gonna shrink this cone
down and essentially once something ends
up outside the cone you need to
introduce a spline point so at this
point when we enter this algorithm
you'll already introduce the spine point
B so C is the current point and you can
see here U is C plus error l is C minus
r and these are these error bounds which
I talked about earlier
so this is going to bring the initial
kind of like
cone step one
then we get a new point to move snow
forward this green line means that this
point is actually sitting between within
the error bar which means like this you
don't need to introduce new spine part
this is fine right like we can keep
going
but now you're going to look at the
error bounds now we're looking at the
new potential upper bound this red dot
line here means that this is actually
wider error bound which means that I
don't press the need like I'm not
allowed to widen about not only allow to
kind of tighten the bound
but on the L side you see that the new L
is much closer than the old L which
means that the cone actually gets
tightened so it keeps doing this until
you eventually something ends up outside
the cone and then you restart the
processing producing a spline point
yeah and this is how the actual diagram
looks in the paper I'm just going to
quickly mention different index which is
called a PDM index which is built in the
same way but you don't add the Radix
later so in this Radix spline you build
one spline add the Radix later on Top
This is that build the spline on top of
spline on top of the spline so this like
is a different approach but use kind of
same building blocks they use a slightly
different spline algorithm but they
concepts are kind of the same
I was going to mention it kind of
yeah slightly different thing while on
the topic It's like because when you're
using immutable data you just don't want
to kind of rewrite the resort the base
data so the base that they have a tends
to maybe be unsorted so in this example
it's learned a secondary index
structures paper also at Kip and MIT
group you'll see this just for show
right like this how it looks when it
would have been sorted but that's not
what you store you store this
permutation makes this of course a new
Advanced concept but it's a very useful
trick so a lot of stuff is like
combining quite easy to use things
together and actually get the results
you want
this paper they also have some hash bits
to be able to avoid looking at the base
textbooks obviously like when you go
into the base that you're going to get
some random access it's not going to be
as good as basically sort in the first
place but that's kind of a different
thing
anyway we're moving on to Adaptive
indexing
so this is like a highly influential
paper by Idris from 2007. again it kind
of predates this kind of machine
learning thing it drives in his group
has some more modern interesting funky
stuff but kind of genetically breeding
data structure and stuff like that and
figure out which data structure like the
perfect ones pure thing and they build
it down as kind of like a the kind of
first principles but we're going to
focus this much more simpler thing which
like what it really just does is
incrementally sort a column so you'll
have an unsorted column and then as the
queries come in you will do like one
round or quick sort called the quick
select and then you just basically sort
as much you need but not more
so this sounds good but it requires
tracking the piece boundaries so this
like often when you read these papers
like okay how do they actually do that
because actually you need another data
structure to figure out so I'm going to
show you how this looks and it has some
drawbacks we're gonna not go into that
right now there are many follow-up
papers and some of them are linked to in
my references yeah so here we have an
unsorted column column A in comes the
query right like it's larger than 10
less than 14. so what it does and this
is the correcting right like if you look
up like between 10 like it moves
everything below 10 into the first piece
and everything about 40 in the third
piece and then in the second piece
that's going on where data you're
looking for right so this approach
allows to avoid certain entire column
you can potentially ask yourself when is
it worth actually trying to vote this
and it's always something you run would
have to kind of look at more closely it
keeps going and it keeps building more
and more piece now you can see here on
the right hand side it's actually really
eventually become a problem this amount
of pieces and you need to track them So
eventually to make this converge either
by I'm not going to sort below a
specific size or I'm just gonna do the
sword once I reach a specific size so
you don't have to track too many pieces
there are many variants in these papers
it's quite interesting to draw some
multi-dimensional versions yeah so the
final argument I'm going to talk about
in this section is instance optimized
system I'm going to roll this very
quickly because this is a vision paper
by Madden from 2022 I discovered this
paper was researching for this talk I
saw I missed this came out early this
year this embraced separation store
compute the other papers they are more
like low level data structure stuff
right then kind of building small
indexes like this is like more strategic
like building on a system level and it
seems to automatically create and modify
indexes and the goal is to minimize
object access so this is quite close to
the stuff like I'm looking for so this
is a very interesting approach or like
to me it's quite interesting what
they're going to come up with so they
apparently kind of Open Source and stuff
but I haven't seen that happening yet
so here are a classic separation storage
compute diagram on top we have some
compute nodes and they're kind of more
or less independent in the bottom you
have a cloud storage where these kind of
what they call yeah this data containers
sit and they're always kind of immutable
and they kind of build up depending on
what's happening in the system they also
have this concept of in-memory
containers which are kind of a little
bit like that after index it's not
directly they don't talk about like they
refer to the cracking paper but
I see it like anything like you can do
slightly different things on the
computer than the things you actually
want to store in orbit store yeah so
this short and last section is about the
engineering we are kind of embarking on
and we are kind of been doing some of
this exists some of the stuff we're
going to do now right so this is going
to in a way re-group some of the stuff
I've talked about so far but I'm only
kind of like the way I think about and
the way we kind of potentially want to
approach about it so index immutable
data right think make like you have like
prayers on one side and a mutual data on
the other side in the middle you have
derived index they're only there to help
you solve like the latest probably you
don't really care about them so much
like you need to do some engineering to
make this problem go away but the point
is not to build this more than it needs
to be so one needs to measure everything
all the time and think about it doesn't
actually pay its way do I need a neural
network here or not right yeah so you
need to navigate the store by layers of
indexes and this is very important right
like initially you want to have just a
very small and it can tell you of what
exists nobody store and then based on
that based on actual usage you will then
basically derive more and more advanced
index as you go
so the goal again is to minimize latency
yeah so light indexes these are for
storage as I mentioned they're created
on demand and they will be creating the
background these are not happening
during the query they will be happening
based on what queries and what activity
has been going on they are it important
they are mutual and they're shared so
that's kind of like a lot of the
immutability goodness here right the
data skipping is absolute key and this
is what I mentioned in the previous
slide like you need to have some small
metadata like min max boom filter and
stuff to even be able to cut I don't
want to look at most robust stories most
of the time right like
your data will come in clustered based
on insertion time in an append online
system which is often not the way you
want your data to sit so for example in
copenas paper he suggested you will
store every column in both a sorted and
then kind of like non-sorted version
like it's on append order like this is
not necessarily feasible like when you
get enough data right I knew it's going
to sit somewhere else but you can kind
of drag it towards that direction
depending what's actually happening yes
so adaptive indexing for compute so
these are dynamic in Rome as I mentioned
these could be things like tracking and
there are other similar approaches they
are adapted by workloads this in a way
like they are going to recede these
other things this is like where the
first information that your system comes
in so you can go oh some people are
interested in this data this cannot
potentially be useful to me right like
they're local and they're transient
though you could be using them also
literally like once you've sorted entire
column you could potentially use some of
that to then build the spline on top of
that right
because of this you also run into
concurrent modifications you don't have
all of that kind of like immutability
good stuff right because this is going
to be happening potentially in on the
same box under various ways you
obviously can never we are engineer
around that but you can't ignore it so
wrapping up some Outlook right like
one thing we really use in learning is
for at the moment is most dimensionally
which I haven't talked about which is
used for a bi-temporary so this is a
good paper called learning
multi-dimensional indexes which also in
the reference right which builds some
kind of like learned grid file funkiness
on top of like multi-dimensional data so
I think learned index has a lot of
potential in the multi-dimensional space
even if it may feel a little bit like oh
do I really need this for one
dimensional space and it's most
Dimension space not just about multiple
dimensional data it could be like
correlations between different things
you can see in your data or your virus
so success data search has nothing to do
with learned index but they are like
small for different way different
reasons they are kind of like different
approaches to kind of compress the data
down but not compress that kind of like
g-shipping if I like you know making it
very small while still accessing it
usually feeling very funky bit
techniques right so they are not
necessarily false to access but they can
become very small so they are they allow
you to see some stuff which are
essentially almost impossible because
you can keep a lot more data in Iran
then as I said workload prediction is
going to be kind of a key to actually
make this feasible in practice because
once the data become big and you don't
know you need to start kind of pulling
more and more from the orbit store if
you're good to somehow figure out and
they're all all kinds of things from
very simple things right you know like
I'm just gonna pull in things which I've
recently used like people like this
orbit also like this orbit and stuff
like that or like a funky machine
learning stuff but of course all the
machine learning stuff requires to have
enough data and this data so that is not
like the data itself but the kind of
metric data so you can actually learn
something from it so summer index on
demand think make coplan people do not
delete separation of storage compute
like
you can always talk about many things to
talk about but it's a very important
concept right an academic inspiration
not gospel right if you want to learn a
lot of good stuff from it and it's like
I think to build the kind of system
rebuilding it's almost impossible or
foolish to ignore it but you can't
really like the point does not get
sucked in all the way in right yeah so
as I mentioned several times I have
reference here so we'll be on post
you're gonna show the link and here's
the link so at this link you can find
the slides which you reference if
something of this was interesting to you
you can go here and actually have a
deeper look so on that note thank you
very much
foreign
[Applause]
for questions someone has a question but
yes
yeah okay so the question is like how
does the spline mapping look in the
Radix
yeah well I don't I don't know so the
question is like how is this related log
structure merge trees more or less right
so I think the short answer I wouldn't
say they're directly related they're
obviously similar ideas you need to kind
of map and track where the data sits but
you can then later apply a log structure
style techniques to merge several
indexes and data together but during
this process except that it maps to some
data I wouldn't personally say it has a
direct connection to that
yeah so okay so the question is like the
lightings are immutable what happens
when you mutated data essentially
underlying data you're indexing which
actually then connects backly this log
structured merge three thing because one
thing you can do is you can try to merge
a new index based on the kind of new
mutable data so you don't try to mute
the data you actually currently have
there are also I have not mentioned this
in this talk right there are Dynamic
learned indexes but they don't
necessarily map well to this kind of a
mutable store in an object store case
because like once you store it not be
stored you don't necessarily want to
change that file but you can then merge
several files potentially to get a
better like sorting thing happening on
top
okay thank you
sorry the question is our learning this
is taking the something about size sorry
could you repeat the question yeah
yeah no they're going to be magnitude
smaller than the data you're indexing
this kind of the problems can be smaller
and that's the kind of one of the points
of them is that they're going to be
smaller and say if you build like a tree
structure yourself which sits over like
you can all the also very good books you
can mapped out columns you're directly
which are going to work like all other
columns but they happen to be indexes so
generally that's the important lighting
they're going to be very small but
they're going to set the father
something to be small but it needs very
small compared to the data actually
index so this is one of the
um I guess one of the real motivations
for the entire learning indexing thing
there's also talk about performance but
I haven't really touched up on that
because it's like some kind of
discussion like how fast there is really
in practice but I would mainly use them
for this size
okay
okay I think that's it thank you very
much
[Applause]